what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today i can't
believe it we didn't just get the entire
phase 5 reveal but marvel studios gave
us phase six as well including the date
of the fantastic four and two new
avengers movies that are going to be
coming out in the same year so let's go
ahead and just break it on down right
away we also got our very first teaser
for black panther to wakanda forever and
it looks absolutely amazing i'll be
doing a breakdown of the wakanda forever
trailer tomorrow so keep an eye out for
that but let's dive into the huge
reveals of marvel's phase six now they
didn't give us all of phase six but they
have teased us with probably the biggest
things of phase 6. to start off with the
biggest news we have an official release
date for the fantastic four the
fantastic four will release on november
8th of 2024
just a little over two years from now
that is when marvel's first family is
going to be making their debut now they
really didn't give us any other
information about the fantastic four
simply when it is going to come out and
some people are saying that the
fantastic four are going to start phase
six but if you take a look here it
actually says there's a project coming
out of fall of 2024. of course we'll
speculate what that's going to be in a
different video but for now let's move
on to the avengers announcements we are
getting two avengers movies in one
year the first one is coming out may 2nd
2025 and it is avengers the kang dynasty
now we talked about this yesterday but
it was a little bit of a premature
reveal now marvel studios has officially
revealed it and we can talk about it but
before we break this down and what to
expect in the king dynasty let's talk
about the second avengers film which is
of course avengers secret wars
now this is pretty crazy we have two
avengers films coming out in the same
year the king dynasty is may 2nd of 2025
and avengers secret wars is november 7th
of 2025 as well we've never had this
happen before even infinity war and
in-game were a year apart and i'm kind
of thinking that avengers the king
dynasty and secret wars are a part one
and a part two that's why they are so
close together it's also pretty amazing
that we are getting these avengers films
so soon and of course we have to talk
about the x-men don't worry we will talk
about that in this video because there
are some release dates that don't have
titles revealed to them yet and i'm
assuming the mutants are there somewhere
but first let's talk about what to
expect from these avengers films well
the first one is called the kang dynasty
now i think this title is actually very
important if you are unfamiliar with
what a dynasty is the definition is a
line of hereditary rulers of a country
or a succession of people from the same
family who play a prominent role in
business politics or another field and
this is coming straight from oxford
languages now the reason that i think
that this is important because this
talks about a line of hereditary rulers
or a line of rulers from the same family
throughout generations of time so this
title is implying that kang actually has
a dynasty however the dynasty is simply
going to be himself kang the conqueror
was originally nathaniel richards who
was from the future he managed to put
together a time machine and travel back
in time all the way to ancient egypt and
he actually became the pharaoh rama tut
so kang's dynasty could have started in
ancient egypt and i believe that that is
the route that they're going to go now
if we go back to loki season one the
ending told us pretty much everything
that we needed to know and this is
actually why i think avengers the king
dynasty is actually part one and
avengers secret wars is part two because
kang is the one who originally started
the multiversal war avengers secret wars
in the comics is about the multiverse
specifically the destruction of the
multiverse and pretty much it fusing
into just one universe one planet battle
world we'll get to that in just a second
but kang and all of his variants are the
one that originally started the
multiversal war until he who remains
ended it using goliath however he was
very clear when talking to loki and
silvie that if they killed him his
variants would be released all of these
different branch timelines would be
created and variants of king the
conqueror would exist in each of these
branch timelines now before this there
were no other kang the conquerors in the
mcu he who remains made it to where
there was only him that's why he
controlled the timeline however he is
now gone and the variants are released
we're going to see one a main one in
ant-man and the wasp quantomania he is
going to be the main villain along with
modok they did reveal that modok is
indeed going to be a villain in ant-man
3. so that's going to be fun as well but
in terms of kang's dynasty the kang
dynasty i'm assuming that different
variants of kang from different points
in time are going to end up on our earth
i also believe that they'll be on other
earths and other universes and
eventually the universes are going to
have to start communicating with each
other because again the next avengers
film that comes out months later not
years months later is secret wars and
the story of secret wars is that
incursions occur in the multiverse until
they eventually all collide and this is
kind of what we want to happen because
this is where we are going to see all of
the different variants from different
universes come together in one universe
so kang's dynasty is going to be the
cause of secret wars so we're going to
start to see multiple variants of kang
throughout the mcu starting in phase 5
with ant-man and the wasp quantum mania
we'll get a little bit of his backstory
and maybe some other variants back
stories as well because they're going to
be different they'll establish the
character and that will eventually take
them to avengers the king dynasty where
the avengers go okay we have to stop
this guy now i don't think they actually
will or if they do i think it's going to
be too late because we would not be
getting avengers secret wars if they
were successful so i'm kind of thinking
the kang dynasty is going to end
somewhat similar to avengers infinity
war the bad guy wins and then the
avengers have to do some true avenging
but the great part is it's not just
going to be the avengers that's the
whole point of secret wars and the
multiverse we're going to have the x-men
there as well of course along with a
fantastic four which have already been
revealed but like i mentioned before
they only revealed three projects of
marvel's entire phase six now of course
this is because they're saving the rest
of the reveals for d23 which is coming
in a couple of months so you have to
imagine since they revealed the
fantastic four release date since they
revealed something as huge as the next
two avengers films you have to imagine
that these other projects that were not
revealed here have to be pretty dang
amazing because two avengers films is
pretty much as big as it gets but at the
same time we know marvel has to save
something to wow us with at disney's d23
event so i'm assuming that some of these
dates on here that don't have titles are
for not only one x-men project but
multiple x-men projects because if you
think about it you have to be familiar
with some of the x-men that are going to
be in secret wars otherwise you're not
going to be too invested in the
characters so here we have 11 projects
for phase six that's eight projects that
have not been announced that i'm
assuming are all going to be announced
at d23 also keep in mind that the next
spider-man film is probably in one of
these slots and at the last san diego
comic-con that marvel attended in 2019
kevin feige did mention the mutants
which means they are coming so once
again i assume that's for d23 and is
going to go in probably a early slot in
phase 6 because again there has to be
some time since they're introduced so
they can fit well in the king dynasty
and secret wars so phase five and phase
six today that have been revealed have
been nothing short of spectacular i
don't think fans thought we'd get an
avengers film so soon let alone two in
one year but this also makes me even
more excited for d23 now because you
know they saved some good stuff for that
so let me know what you think about all
of these reveals today in the comments
down below it's been a great day i want
to thank everybody for supporting the
channel without you all i could not do
this look out for my black panther
wakanda forever teaser trailer breakdown
tomorrow be sure to follow me on
instagram and twitter for some updates
and as always i love you all in every
universe woof
you